une nouvelle nation verra-t-elle le jour
dans le pacifique pour la deuxième fois
en moins de deux ans les habitants de la
nouvelle calédonie sont appelés à
choisir entre l'indépendance de
l'archipel ou son maintien dans la
république française
dès l'ouverture des bureaux de vote tout
près de 180 mille électeurs sont
attendus on note une influence très
importante avec un taux de participation
estimé à plus de 49% à midi à référendum
dont l'issue reste incertaine
l'écart entre les deux camps pourrait se
resserrer
si le nom l'emportent une troisième
consultation est possible d'ici à 2022
un scrutin qui divise les calédoniens
mes attentes c'est que la stalle
l'économie de la caille denis se
stabilise et que bien qu'on en finisse
avec le pour l'indépendance ou pas pour
l'indépendance bon moi je suis
calédonienne je suis pas pour
l'indépendance le même rattachée à la
france et je suis français je me sens
française et calédonienne et j'ai des
craintes pour demain parce que je me dis
si c'est louis pour l'indépendance mais
on sait pas ce que demain nous réserve
parce qu'il ya rien de concret de défini
ils ont aucun avenir de on sait pas ce
qui va être fait même s'il aura le oui
où ça va rien n'a changé quoi ça a ruiné
sa va pas changer
on verra ça au jour le jour d'après moi
ce que je veux c'est que voilà tous tout
le monde se calme qui la paix revienne
et
en soie noire joue en blanc verte les
couleurs qu'on s'entende bien comme
avant on est dans un pays démocratique
et on cherche à avoir une souveraineté
parce qu'on est le peuple premier je
suis apte à naples mais ces pays et
c'est pour cela on y croit moi j'y crois
dur comme fer monique rock indépendant
sa note aux icônes meoli tracy francs
jusqu'au bout faut avoir les sports ce
que vous croyez aux cultures votre
addition to c'est ça qui fait notre
dépendance ont fait pour moi c'est le
but le but final l'indépendance a eu des
morts il ya eu des conflits
du coup l'indépendance la réponse à la
fin la fin de ses coups que c'est cool
et de sortir